che cos'è l'insalatiera delle bambole
challenge slime questa voce invece di
ingrediente piccolo verso ingrediente
grande ingredienti piccolissimo quindi
avremo degli ingredienti in miniatura
minuscoli troppo divertente
questa volta però invece di scegliere
noi l'ingrediente grande no io segneremo
sempre noi però ben darti ama pescare
uno di questi fogli e questi giorni
capita dovremmo prendere l'ingrediente o
normale o piccoli come sempre alla fine
la challenge cup e le più crescenti
piccolissimo normale tutti a giovedì
qui tutti e due perché se non mangiare
come questo giochino comunque alla fine
quindi come stai freddo basa la bellezza
dello slam ei suoi comodi feriti e
portati che occorre l'assaggio un mi
piace se volete vedere altri to hell
challenge a 15 mila mi piace faremo
un'altra slime chandler brady e arrivano
vediamo chi inizia carta forbice sasso
teoria ma allora io mi devo bendare
vittoria mettere gli ingredienti quella
dentro e poi io dovrò pescare sempre da
bendata uno di questi due folli ma una
volta che l'ho beccato dovrò vedere che
ingrediente mi è capitato se normale o
piccolissima no aspetta lì devo prima
mostrare parliamo questo che è
l'ingrediente normale
[Musica]
ecco resto non so se si vede che mi
credete piccolissimo
quindi mettiamo ingrediente l'alba le e
credetemi
si vende si ok allora mi deve stare
allegri forti questi giorni c'era tutto
e devo pescara chieti
allora è allora 62 serve questo vediamo
normale e quindi evitare piccolissimo
conio una ciotola io quello normale
quella piccolissima e non vedo l'ora di
vedere come farà ma che cos'è
l'insalatiera delle bambole signora io
sono in vantaggio e viale giotto normale
resta aggiornato che a me quindi tu devi
bendata aiuto che paura quindi homos
appoggiare qui che vado a prendere il
secondo ingrediente allora secondo
ingredienti abbiamo quello normale ok e
guardate un po questo e quello piccolo
non posso dirtelo ma spero proprio che
ti capiti beh vuol dire se capita a me
sarà un bel disastro mescolare tutto
nella ciotola grande e con questo odio
spero proprio che non capiti a me
provare volevo dire fare allora mettiamo
e uno spezia sono i segni questa tecnica
ben da piccolissimo era meglio
fisicamente ma la piccolissima federale
questa volta che un po di sfortuna
[Musica]
mescolare invece la destra dove si
svolgerà il e dintorni sale eni bocchino
sono un disastro questa già nel sommesso
verdi ce la faccio la regola punta con
la punta di casa base come membro della
rai tutta lì
la vita di sistema il casco
a nanna
[Musica]
e allora aspetta che mi faccio vedere
questo l'ingrediente normale e questo è
l'ingrediente piccolissimo cia ok allora
fatto si può pescare deve pescare allora
aspetta quelle scegli questo perché c'è
così tanto silenzio adesso perché sente
stato silenzio ha fatto rumore
piccolissimo normale un po di carta
normale avevamo prodotti verdi il mini
colorate
che carino rosa e vita ecco verde ufo
non rifiuti perché st ciotola
va beh insomma prima di riuscirci invece
tutto questo colorante mi metterò
soleste di quella molla e più smalto
entrato perché come farai a lo stesso il
turno più importante perché i masi ha
visto che non è ancora capitata
sicuramente sarà la colla e qua sarà
molto importante perché sm capitala con
la piccola morise possa riuscire a
mescolarlo con il cucchiaino minuscola
siete capitana con la grande giorno è
che in futuro è importante ma non è
giusto tutto ingredienti grazie allora
abbiamo l'ingrediente normale poi
abbiamo l'ingrediente l'ingrediente in
miniatura di un poco di questo caso tale
perché ci sono tre fogli qua dimenticato
[Musica]
devo dire soggetti finiti l'inizio
bellissimo dello stivale così questi due
sono ora si sa la al vero crisi
economica sì effettivamente più facile
nella tua foto la vergogna e io invece
una cosa normale che blu però si
mischierà con il rosa rosso non lo so
che ora vediamo se riusciamo e non si sa
come scalare questa slide con le cose
vivo tutto le grandi che abbiamo ok
inizio provare frames lime questa è la
mia azione gigante fortuna da gioco da
gigante voleva mettere la crollati come
un mini cucchiaino non è messo troppa di
colla certo che la vetta ma non posso
mettere troppo altrimenti non riuscirò
mai ad attivarla interessa ecco qua è
già troppa sicuramente
si trova guerra secondo te io potevo
mettere qua dentro vaghissima mesi più
guarda lo stesso quantitativo che posso
mettere la mia ciondolino guarda che
questo e molto di più di quanto ne
mettere situ poi vado a mettere il mio
colorante rosso che però non si sta
molto bene con questo blog
un bel colore fammi ma chiaro tutti i
membri
ecco amy di cocaina ora si può provare a
mescolare non so come ancora non mi sono
macchiate tutte le mani sta diventando
una pappetta strana macchia frutta leva
rinviato tech e nocciola spatola grande
che bello che mai ad attivarlo
sicuramente relatore ok ho messo il
bicarbonato la soluzione per lenti spero
stessi attivi ma è molto faticoso
girarla con questo make ok sporcarlo
tutte le vane ma posso se si sta
attivando non riesco a capire si sta
uscendo dal web ma quel cancello un po
complicato però altrimenti perdonata
legge prova ad aggiungere un pochettino
di carpi il duomo di qualche fortunato
con questo gioco alla grande ruolo però
sono sfortunate con il cucchiaio perché
piccolo bar batista tutto attaccando al
cucchiaio
all
ormai cucchiaino lasciano dentro come
decorazione a 0
idea questa settimana è sopravvissuto
per il cucchiaino
proviamo a mescolarli ovviamente è
piccolo piccolo alla fine per fortuna il
colore è uscito un blu scuro non è
diventato marrone note celestri con rock
sito blu scuro a prima di farlo vedere
meglio vediamo come su quello di vitale
chi sporca per far abitare con la mia mi
ricevuto l'amicizia
riecco la colla mettiamo subito la colla
e vediamo uscita incollato tutto carina
bastava troppo col cav è troppo ecco chi
e come faccio tirarla con lucchetti e
basta obiettivi ancora un portato quella
che con l'aiuto la gigante non ammessa
puro bis un cruccio del colorante bravo
perché non ti capita troppo ma ascolta
non possiamo non possiamo fare capire
che se di questo mi dà alla minuscola
solo per farvi capire la differenza
questo è tutto quello con cui ha girato
a rita che è stato come lo devo cedere
york e no giriamo e chiaro ha detto
piano di così
l'unica ferita che bello funziona che
bel verde di attenzione perché poi sarà
anche il bicarbonato allora mettiamo
prima o il bicarbonato
si vede che promesse bicarbonato e poi
mettiamo attiva forse non messo un pò
troppo troppo liquido devo aggiungere
più colla anzi niente lo dico ma ci
vuole più bicarbonato nostro shadows
tacendo ti attivando incredibile se
riuscito a fischiare ma quella fare
tutto questo ma non è molto di questo è
un po un po lo slime di natale e natale
sta arrivando aiuto si è capottata la
ciotola la ciotola non si staccano
all'osso
il più grande lo slime stellaccio sala
ecco lo vincolava la vita aspetta
mettiamo un altro po di sano serio per
letti che mi era caduta ecco
[Risate]
ecco qua il mio slime ho lasciato anche
cucchiaino come differente a lago verso
il servizio vitale
ho fatto il mio la città grazie
anzi ometto direttamente nella giunta
[Musica]
votate chi vince votate votate stata
super divertente votare il vincitore nel
sondaggio se volete altri slam challenge
la sorte un bel mi piace questo video
ora mi lascero buca 4 caso in lire su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]